[Music]
all right this one's a little like it's
a little sad I don't believe you sad are
the better that's what they always say I
finally want to feel something so all
right
this 40-year old man who was supporting
his family by operating a raishin
trashin shop because of covin 19 he was
under immense financial burden to the
point that he fell into a really deep
depression he didn't see a way out
and so he needed to support his family
so he ended up deciding to take his own
life so they can get that sure insurance
money well then if you take your own
life do you still get things you know
you don't cuz you cancel the contract I
mean if you in a crafty way or something
like you they can prove that you
committed suicide your family isn't get
money yeah that job like yeah we can't
give you money I'm gonna prove why I'm
the insurance guy who's gonna take your
family's money every time I think about
those insurance people it always reminds
me of one of the Saw movies do you
remember how one of the Saw movies he
got the people who worked at this
particular insurance company and then
they had to do his his twisted little
game I didn't watch it my dreams were
scary enough it was like saw three or
some [ __ ] one of them I don't remember
the other ones only the one where he was
always in the room at the same time what
a great game that's a quote I know that
one no but yeah like he was just like
punishing these people because they were
looking for ways to not help people who
needed help gotcha
yeah so anyway back to this story Jude
saw a guy with his little cheeks the
spirals okay so back to this story
though so he ended up taking out okay so
he he wasn't able to muster up the
courage to do it himself
and maybe it was like an insurance thing
where he maybe couldn't have done it
himself so he took out a personal loan
of seven thousand nine hundred dollars
and he planned to have himself murdered
so he hired an assassin with the loan so
yes why did he brainstorm like a
traction you know when you're a kid and
you want to pull your own tooth out so
you could tie your tooth to adorn
because these doctors do it higher gonna
do all that how you gonna tie a string
to the trigger put it somewhere maybe
put it in like I'll put that gun in the
doc pop slam the door so it looks like
the dog pulled the trigger on you it's
like home alone [ __ ] just go walk him in
the [ __ ] desert like a lot of happens
to a lot of people to get lost hiking
somewhere else what appeal I had a bunch
of Capri Suns is really hydrated and he
doesn't die oh I don't know you juice a
lot of water because he doesn't know you
can get poisoned by oh you juice too
much water that's myself no z11 there's
a lot of things going on here yeah I've
learned no but by accident okay I saw
it's not easy to die is it I was
throwing hope the water cuz I don't know
I was trying to challenge myself to
drink a two liter bottle of water and I
had like four of them cannot really and
I was like maybe that's why you don't
drink water no I do that about the old
brandy well you're just the most fun kid
ever um I was very depressed and during
this time I actually had the same what
else is this guy where I'm like please
someone come and do this for me cuz I
can't do it did anyone go camera
throw-ups clear I did myself cuz I was
throwing up and I saw it I was like oh
[ __ ] this everybody come look Ted stuard
Crystal Pepsi it was actually a spray
bottle that I rinsed out and I put water
in there way to repurpose that good for
you still tastes like sprite on the in
time
well what's this alright so this was so
he try to hire an assassin this was in
India and Delhi Delhi India yeah so he
so the cops are saying that well first
of all they found his body hanging from
a tree and they immediately ruled out
suicide because of the fact that his
hands were tied and so that's when they
started an investigation and they
discovered through call records and
social media activity that he had
contacted this 18 year old student and
apparently it was the student who he
hired to get himself killed
yeah yeah murder him and so they just
said I don't want to do it so the
student ended up getting a friend
who then ended up getting another friend
okay with this Chinese assassin white
remember that one yeah
but so then it's like a Russian doll of
assassins it's like I hire you you hire
me I hide not a guy I don't want to do
today so it ended up being a total of
four people involved in this man's
murder and and so they're saying that
load they're like you want to kill I
don't want to kill that's seven thousand
dollars now pay you like three thousand
but it until they only get like a
hundred bucks each now they got a
thousand two hundred
because they did split okay so um
initially there they said Oh first of
all they did confess to the murder and
they said that he contacted that one
student and then that he wanted to get
him like for them to shoot him but then
an arms dealer refused to sell a pistol
to the team or eighteen year old and
scruples arms dealer is like no I don't
you are not the terrorist I don't want
you to give only little children little
either one I said little not this year
too old are you a drug dealer
no no suicide I don't condone yes so
then that's when this man thought up of
the idea to for them to hang him so he
brought the rope and it's not a quick
day Owen let's see jump high enough I
suppose
you hope that the neck is broken and you
choke on immediately but if you don't
then you're suffocating till death yeah
oh so then he instructed before guys
that so he chose the spot where right
there who's gonna be hanged
that is my death and then once the time
came he asked the four guys to tie his
hands but to keep make sure that that
they leave his ID in his pockets to make
sure that his body was easily
identifiable and the idea to my face
[Music]
give him a name his driver's license is
on his cheek why couldn't we just
if no one wants to do a violent act they
could have just made a thing of
quicksand and set up a camera if you
make a thing of quicksand like slowly uh
that's pretty violent that was sand in
my mouth it's better than snapping your
neck
that's way faster I think that's faster
what is the NAP of your neck oh if that
doesn't work ouu I don't know here go
keep talking everybody why doesn't he
eat like a big heavy meal an English
woman there cramp
and you need to leave the evidence for
the cops or the family can get the money
yeah what about alligators you can hold
the the ID like this holding all the way
up then that way you're under the sand
but the IDS right here you gotta find a
way to do it like you fall asleep
peacefully carbon monoxide you can
accent fall asleep in your car in the
garage there that's a common suicide
move so that it's considered half
brainstorm too many suicides for this
guy who already died so he died right
yeah he died already we don't look at my
ideas so so he died yeah he accomplished
this tragic goal we're gonna need a
Turner warning yeah so he died and then
and then what happened afterwards like
obviously they found out that it was a
suicide right or an assassin who exposed
the plot are they going to jail and miss
his family getting money no that's the
problem so right we all want the family
to get money that's fill an ongoing
investigation the family is having a
really hard time too unlike to believe
that he was the one that wanted to die
so there it seems like they don't want
to accept the fact that he did the
suicide himself like he planned it out
well cuz it could be that this was a
part of a labyrinth scam and the four
guys maybe extorting him yeah
it could be like you just don't know
yeah that's true there is another side
to this then how did the guy even know
he has life insurance what if they have
some dirt on up like I know you cheated
or whatever and then they extort up and
like I now like you want to live with
shame I'll tell your whole family or you
can do this and then get then they
couldn't collect insurance and then
whatever and then they put life
insurance on them that's the last
picture he took it's from like the 80s
do you know how much he would have given
his family if it I don't because what if
it's like eight hundred dollars in his
life oh we could have done a GoFundMe
dude you should have told us I had that
in the mattress and what is a
repurposing store the whole time I'm
trying to wonder what that is
Russian purpose income from from the
government and stuff that's a store it's
a ration store maybe he created one when
I hear rations I never think of the full
thing so I feel like a corner of a rice
krispies treat or like I feel like a
handful of cereal it's not like the
whole box its rations you know it's like
half a samosa
yeah that's why when you watching the
Martian with that that Matt Damon he
gets too rash his own potatoes and EEP
bit like a [ __ ] slices them up into
small cubes yeah so when I think of a
ration shop I think everything a piece
of that product he'll true
those are leftovers I think of MREs dude
those metal gears that's all no gear
solid bro [ __ ] yes I got that damn [ __ ]
man you know you know there's this new
phenomenon about like suicide and a high
rate of suicide is happening with kids
under like 14 or something because well
I mean like you're insanely
impressionable and then during that age
everyone's like depressed cuz your
hormones are [ __ ] wild and then also
now you add on top of that social media
where other 15 year olds are rich as
hell and they have like brand new cars
that [ __ ] and you compare yourself to
them and realize or and then you think
you're not that good not even just 15
year-olds me and Nicki been watching
that love Island cuz we [ __ ] love
that love Island UK and part of the
thing is we don't Google the show until
after the show well we've been googling
the show after the show and we find out
because you want to know did the couples
make it but most the time we're like wow
these people killed themselves oh my god
it's like [ __ ] song
she's like an attachment or this person
he can never show all right like like we
just did a JK news with the with the
girl from that Japanese dating show that
everyone likes and these are hot people
yeah you wouldn't expect hot people up
obviously just being narrow-minded you
wouldn't expect them to like think their
life is so easy
exactly but you're like man that person
killed themselves holy [ __ ] yeah I knew
someone that um was he was a sole
provider of his family and he felt like
because his financial situation was
going to be threatened that he wasn't
going to be able to provide for his
family so he did attempt to kill himself
to get the insurance
listen there's GoFundMe joking aside
everything aside check out the suicide
hotline it's great it works and your I
know you feel here in a tailspin and you
feel like it's all over but really there
is light coming like it's not over this
too shall pass like everything is
temperate I feel like that's one thing
we really need to teach in school is the
how to handle that [ __ ] how to fight
through adversity like non-stop like is
if there's a program where we can give
people hope because I think what happens
is people feel like there's no options
so then they resort to suicide because
they don't have hope and options yeah
they also don't teach people how to fail
properly too because since you're a kid
you ever since you're a kid your parents
are telling like you have to do this and
they accomplish this and you're gonna be
great you're gonna be that well they
make you think failing is a bad thing
yeah or like they tell you like you know
you can't fail this and you have an
athlete that's a worse [ __ ] thing
ever and then now as as teenagers when
they fail something yeah they should
have did what our parents did and called
us all failures and if we fail it's like
I am what I am good but we also live at
a time where you have canceled culture
just wait till the suicides come from
that and that's that's where I'm I'm
scared of too is I hope that people can
try to look for the light even when it's
the roughest toughest roughest [ __ ] cuz
it will come it's heavy bro but you do
but you just have to just break through
you know and it's easier said always
[Music]
you